so the spoiler dog from Mockingjay and
it's an official spoiler warning for you
guys I'm going to talk about spoilers in
the movie Mockingjay part 1 hopefully
after the weekend you've had time to see
the movie if you haven't you've been
warned that's all I got to say about
that [ __ ] this isn't a play-by-play of
the movie or anything like that I know
I'm gonna forget to talk about some
things I'm just not going to touch on
some things people are gonna be like oh
no probably I did but I'm not going to
be here for two hours talking about a
two hour movie in the course of a few
minutes I'll talk about some things that
would be spoilers in the movie I'll talk
about some quips and things that I
thought when I saw the movie or upon
further reflection of the movie in any
case Mockingjay part 1 starts out
Katniss is all crying and she's freaked
out because you know life sucks cuz her
home was blown up all this [ __ ] that put
you in a mood help Seymour Hoffman's
like you need to be our symbol of hope
the Mockingjay it's not really having it
and there's like hey how about we take
her home yeah home district 12 you
remember that [ __ ] yeah otherwise known
as the playground gravel yeah you
remembered the playground in elementary
school that gravel that's this now and
she's walking through this place is a
boneyard it was actually almost like a
holy [ __ ] that's like Holocaust stuff
would you see the dead bodies and the
burned people and again I like the
propaganda stuff I'm PETA's on TV and
then Stanley Tucci you know he's like
I'll tell us about these these traitors
this Katniss who everyone loved betrayed
her country her smear in her name she's
fighting the good fight but everyone
thinks she's an [ __ ] now because
that's just how the media is gonna play
and Peter's like yeah I want them all
the lay down arms we don't have to kill
anybody so they're like you know what
Katniss if you're going to do this
you're going to be our Mockingjay you're
going to be our symbol which means we
need to do propaganda this is really
sweet scene where they start doing these
propaganda pieces and their shitty
they're terrible but it's really
hilarious to say it's all choreographed
but she just sucks that it's just like I
stand among the nation um we should
fight for puppies and Christmas and
stuff mmm what's that word sex just
nonsense and Haymitch was like yeah I
think she's one of those people bare
with me now I think she needs to
actually be natural I've just say what's
on her mind so Department President
Snow's like a hospital with wounded
women and children kaboom dead that's
the scene in the trailer she's like if
we burn you burn with us I was like yeah
that's the propaganda piece were looking
for right there I love the scene where
Katniss is like we free Peeta and
Phoenix chick otherwise you can find
yourself another Mockingjay philip
Seymour Hoffman's like right there
that's the stuff
told you I wasn't wrong about her
there's a kind of funny Philip Seymour
often added more humor to this movie
than I thought he would add I never saw
Philip Seymour Hoffman as the comedy
relief but this movie did have comedy
relief just happen naturally it's one of
the things I liked about there was some
intent seems to and the evil empire is
just bombing the [ __ ] out of them
they're just waiting it out and do you
see the pavement cracking in the ceiling
then they go up there and there's all
these roses everywhere you're like Oh
President Snow and his roses he's
taunting her which is interesting
because when she went back to district
12 there was a rose in a vase you're
like oh he's taunting her again which
makes him the dumbest idiot ever like if
I was the dictator of this world I would
get [ __ ] done I would put the dick in
dictator and I mean it I trap a liar or
a bomb or something to that Rose which
he picks it out like pink huh
Dunham or Mockingjay problem at all you
have fixed your problem alright maybe
you don't want to use a nuke maybe you
can just use a grenade he can blow her
up and then blow off the hospital anyway
and be like Katniss died in that
hospital she strapped a bomb to her
chest and kill everybody in there I'm
just a collab this threat this traitor
was dealt with before more human lives
were lost
sorry and then you guys rule your shitty
little world how you want done I didn't
let that scene where they're going in
there doing that ray that military scene
they're getting PETA and Phenix doing
his monologue he's like hey I know some
things about President Snow and he just
does this monologue about President Snow
just information you didn't know I love
that [ __ ] I love it when you find out a
little more about villains you know how
I like that but I thought about one
scene because it goes from Finnick to
the raid scene and then Finnick to the
raid scene and it jumps back and forth
like that which was cool but I couldn't
help but think when I was watching the
movie I was like I wonder what that
would be like if they went to Finnick
and then the raid then back to Finnick
and then when it went back to the raid
you just keep hearing Phenix monologue
over the raid say it shows them raiding
the building and you just hear Finnick
talking about presidents no I don't know
I'd like for some one reason I want to
see how that would look then they get
Peter back and they're like yeah snow
let us go again which again dissed him
playing his games dude loves playing
with Katniss he just loves playing the
cat-and-mouse game doesn't want to kill
her he just wants to [ __ ] with her what
a really bored guy he must be but then
they have Peter back and Katniss goes to
him and you're like alright maybe
they're rekindled God grabs her by the
neck throws R into the blast throws her
to the ground you start squeezing her
neck and I knock him out though yeah
Peters Peters gone bye-bye econ what
have you got left
and seeing PETA just flailing on his bed
like he's just going nuts he's going
bananas he's just gone but I thought it
was gonna end a little later I thought
she was just gonna grab the pillow and
just chief from Cuckoo's Nest and put
the pillow on the faces put her knee on
it and like oh sorry man it'll be over
in a second just died I don't know if
that's gonna happen Oh spoil that [ __ ]
in the comments section just sayin
that's he just seems so damn gone like
ah PETA yeah he loved you to death
Katniss and now he just tried to
strangle you and kill you cuz I beat the
[ __ ] out of him and gave him evil mutant
bee venom and now he hates your guts
can that be fixed I have no idea but he
looks like he's in pretty bad shape but
judging by the rebellion scenes you saw
in this movie and going into the next
movie I feel like the next movie is
going to be just next-level [ __ ] for the
Hunger Game series I'm hoping it's gonna
be that thing where when it wraps up you
look back and go yes pretty solid right
I already asked you what you thought
about Mockingjay part 1 so ultimately a
book series that you would like to see
adapted into a movie
what is it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more